yeah okay my software tells me I'm life
as usual I really never know if that's
the case so give me a quick message
there in the chat please if I'm really
live I try to check out the twitch
window if I'm really live but um oh you
know right I promised exciting openings
who do I have to do I have to ok let's
try I'm getting I'm getting this guy
Dena meet who is that let's check I tr2
AG a brilliant ok well here we go but
I'm not I'm not guaranteeing any results
with this kind of play so let's see we
start with the Kings gambit think
checking is right and one of them lines
at least ticks hmm probably to see form
that's what you do what you do in the
King's gambit normally I hope I'm not
blundering material early on that can
happen if people if you play the Kings
gambit and you have no idea like i like
i have it can easily blow up in your
face but that looks kind of nice right
am i winning this pawn i'm going to take
this pawn them just grabbing stuff not
sacrificing stuff grabbing stuff here we
go I've got a pawn let's see let's try
to keep everything here hmm he cannot go
rook b8 because my bishop there hmm I'm
a pawn up Wow with the Kings gambit of
all openings and this guy is pretty
strong he's 2500
ha ok but now i'm getting to my old self
trading queens come on trade trade
queens I'm a pawn up why did I blunder
bishop I didn't see that why did I
blunder bishop guys I didn't see that I
really didn't and after I think you're
joking ok let's get let's get this on
the road it's one pawn yeah maybe this
one I don't know it looks logical I was
I'm always worried ok mmm bishop asics I
didn't see that one coming rucca it's
not looking too nice but not a problem
yet yes he wants to trade stuff my eve 1
u 1 square has really weak that's really
weak hmm ok
at the moment he has no direct way they
want to exploit that so let's make some
lift for my king king to age too um now
I don't listen Queen d4 there was a
night on here three all of the time I
don't think windy for was a was possible
um I don't think so yeah i'm using
Blitzen I don't know that other
interface that you mentioned my bubbles
chess I don't know that k Bishop him and
he's weakening his King quite a bit I
understand he wants to get counter play
but it looks it looks kind of strange I
mean his own king is quite a weakened
quite weak and a bit night 2 g1 that's
not looking good but still as king is
pretty weak let's see my night there
would love to get nighty to fon but he's
on a six huh yeah someone said I'm in a
banter ish movie I mean you know if you
play the Kings gambit yeah you should
have a kind of special mood yeah I mean
this is not for the not for the
faint-hearted ok I have to get my queen
ant of the action maybe Quincy to Sosa
move Quincy to to f5 it would be nice
now Queen to f5 okay
yeah I think he wants to take g3 and
possibly check on d6 let's let's quite
neat huh but how hmm still if I go Queen
at 5i can take on f6 though right this
is what the check so rock g3 is not as
problematic okay he went back I can take
their on age 5 mmm group g3 I can also
play Bishop f4 there's nothing wrong
with that probably Bishop d3 maybe
mm-hmm I really want to take on age five
let's take them i really don't see rook
g3 working Bishop d6 check I can't even
take g-form i don't i don't see that
working maybe I'm just blundering here
but I don't see how this should work
there should be six checking g4 but
what's the point ah that's the point i
will now i have no def Knight to f4
hmm 97 instead to move for night at five
maybe well maybe that could be a problem
huh and yeah Queen g6 is nice but
neither five that's really a move maybe
I have to go back check night at five
King edge too let's go back night f5 I
can take the pawn now this is probably
good for me but still kind of kind of
confusing what I'm drinking no I just
just coke it's nothing I mean not cook
but some kind of thing along these lines
um look at you for all right yeah let's
let's just give that back that should be
easiest I'm a ton of pawns up I add g 3g
three he takes on be too that's a good
defense I have to do this yeah for age
54 h5
yeah let's see how can I can I get
Queens traded somehow that would be
quite helpful check check check the only
sf4 check this is not much yeah it's no
draw I have h6 next just marking time
voice is a draw don't tell me that's
three fold Queen have six no one's not
under all right Queen g7 made now coming
oh yeah yes the trade Queens yeah I got
a win in with a king's gambit yes okay
yeah this is a good session already
let's see I really feared I would lose
all games if I play that crap okay let's
see um the latvian a latvian is too bad
i don't play the Latvian yeah I need a
game in the first place
now I love the Halloween game but then
I'm playing something that is at least
quite okay the Kings gambit is at least
quite ok so we form yeah let's let's see
what I can do maybe I get the Schliemann
and yeah let's let's do this this is
this is interesting it's not a boring
opening ok now white can play it in a
boring fashion but it doesn't seem he is
up for that him hmm sure what the only
nights III I don't know notice opening
that well 95 maybe what is lagavulin 16
nights no it's really not nothing fancy
i mean for the german guys shrimp drop
nothing nothing special it's a
sugar-free version at least so it's not
totally unhealthy so I'm what to get rid
of this once you get rid of this um this
annoying pin okay he just went back um
that's good if I take it I don't know
their farm I don't want to take and open
their phone hmm me I am I just I just
recognized that what about g5 always
this this is too wacky I come on
we are out for blood today anyway can I
take on a form or this is to bonkers
right if this is too crazy night XD for
guys it looks very crazy yeah queen age
five o'clock okay that's not even crazy
it's just completely idiotic so let's
not let's not go there um maybe I can do
this try to Castle long do I ever drink
rodless um yeah they're good sure yeah I
now I now see the problem with this okay
I have to take and probably
sure let's do it now I don't play age
three just a long pretty normal lines
but aggressive stuff yam a farm yeah
what can you do I have to get rid of
this bloody pin and if it takes c6
Quincy six that's not that bad we are
not in great shape but it's still okay
playable if you move the bishop I play a
97 I just grabbed at five okay
hmm ok this is this is indeed a
possibility he wants to give some checks
there I can't still have to play this oh
ok yeah I don't know how bad this is
can probably play like we'd be three or
something that would probably give white
a good position yeah the b6 pawn here
Sam is the problem it's no easy way to
cover it i can go Queens is six but
dad's really damn ugly chair I don't
know if I should take at five it's also
very very shaky business look Ezra c3
also coming I probably have to cover
that it looks bad but it'sit's bad okay
maybe this g5 business was a bit much
okay maybe I still get something f6 how
does he keep the pawn down I mean he
definitely if he loses f6 is still as
compensation but one thing is he's
taking quite a bit of time and this is
good what is this for flag actually
martinique that's that's stylish okay
can I take this pawn I think I can don't
see why not okay what is he doing them
if I play Knight a5 is checking on e6
yeah still I still want this idea 9595
okay now maybe I can get Queens traded
do I get Queen straight at Quincy six
right this is a queen trade and this is
this is really a really really helpful
so that I'm not getting getting mated um
yeah let's take now King see 797 this is
almost a clear pawn okay don't want to
take maybe I can take Roxie for thats
that's actually good g5 is not on
unfortunately g4g three okay i see it's
still not not an easy task maybe this
helps night to deform I'm getting here
thats that must be good I can get the
night to this great square yeah i think
i think i'm getting away with that it
looks feels like robbery it's still not
easy to win at least I don't yeah let's
keep stuff closed and then see what to
do g4 yes f form that's not really
helping hmm can I I can maybe try to put
some pressure on the sea porn
I'll still that one maybe that one was
still better I know he can play a four
but I mean he cannot take on e5 ever Wow
he took it check now let's check that
should be some noise attack with rook g8
in the mix up g8 is made now it's a maid
threat okay it's not mated but almost
mmm how do i made him here I don't see
it for up to seven
hmm you can play rook f1 hook to f6
maybe night is king is 796 check maybe I
don't I don't see a win in this position
rook g6 takes check it's not a win
amazing but this this is Sir the bishop
almost looked g5 maybe or the check
their location 5
I don't see a win they're amazingly it's
made yes checkmate wow that was said was
lucky right okay next next game yeah I
couldn't I couldn't really am I couldn't
really a look at the chair I'm sorry
guys i was totally totally in this game
um yeah what what is then the chant have
to make this a little bit bigger there
um another question I played Skyrim will
I play the witcher 3 probably not don't
have time for games really don't don't
have time probably Elder Scrolls 6i will
play because yeah I cannot help myself
okay so let's get going next game that
was very lucky at least timewise it was
very lucky I got a new game requests out
yes I enjoyed the kiss far off short
match quite a bit I mean it's um it's
great to see him yeah people I mean to
two guys play each other that you've
been following for the whole of your
chest Koreans in my case I started chest
1987 1988 when Kasparov was just world
champion for a couple of years and um
yeah short was also I always liked
Nigel's games I mean he really is a
classical attacking player really very
classical style I want to play a game
but I don't get one at the mode so um I
always enjoyed enjoyed both players um
to do them let's trying for something
funky yeah yeah let's play the Colorado
yeah guys don't try this at home it's
not it's not the kind of stuff that i
would recommend to my students but we
said we said before that i'm going to
play it a little bit a little bit crazy
today okay this is not the most
beautiful pawn structure ever Wow okay
but I have the two bishops we should
never forget that and one of them guys
that goes through some kind of yeah I'm
willing to accept some pain for them for
the two bishops yeah this opening is
called the Colorado gambit it's see it's
not particularly great but it is better
than it looks yeah it is better than it
looks it really is I know it looks
terrible and it really looks like a bad
position that i have here Bishop g5
looks kind of bonkers Bishop I wanted to
play Knight age 6 cm
I cannot play that I really cannot a 95
how do i retain somewhat playable
position that experiment really failed
he's 697 that's really terrible okay you
can probably just take it now this might
still be at least viable for a moment
yeah III a Latvian Air the Latvian but
in the Latvian and material down I don't
like that here I'm just having a crap
position but I'm not not like pawns down
for nothing how do I get this untangle I
really have to get out of the pin if he
plays when I'm back in the game here I'm
back in the game it's still not great
but it was worse okay so he will trade
that I don't my dad mmm let's get Bishop
to a six yeah I have the beholder that's
that's really old stuff yeah I looked at
that this is a game that I played in the
80s I also played all these old dungeons
dungeons and dragons games pool of
radiance stuff like that yeah this looks
bad but let's try let's try if he treats
Queen if he trades Queens I'm really
okay he doesn't let's see okay Bishop to
d7 have to go there or intersex and
let's to h6 to have g5 if he goes age
five
don't do that don't play good moves this
this might really be a problem then he's
playing good more subscribe hmm hmm yeah
I cannot really take i cannot really
take it too hmm he's playing period if
he's playing see for next that that's
really a big issue
the night comes to f form hey that's
really that's really really bad I mean
uh okay now i really don't i really
don't have anything here that such bad
can really only hope for him I don't
know grab him he grabbed stuff IAM i
will take these six ok i have to keep it
closed I mean I mean I'm not having huge
Browns here or I don't have much hope to
heaven ok ok maybe I get some kind of
play on the kingside G fire hit come on
let's let's get in let's get this and
maybe i can get getting g5 and things
like that ok
night h2g form but I've FG form hmm now
that wasn't Bell played I have some kind
of play now it's not enough but it's
simply Guidry foreign huh Wow ok and
what now look f5 h5 I guess yeah it's
the taking air forehead well the airport
is I don't care about that one um if I
go rook rook age 5 and am paying F form
but it's important that I keep those two
pawns I don't want to move them push
them so quickly Brooke ef8 rook h5 queen
age six that would win so let's try for
that plan before what are you doing you
have to defend now hmm look aged five
queen age 6 it's really a threat I mean
I'm not sure I mean maybe has to go a
three but that's also really dangerous
okay I have a plan yet do you f3 he has
to go f3 but by now I'm probably sucking
on h2 takes check on g3 King back queen
age 62 c letter know if he gets out of
this I can also go 97 to add five I
think f3 probably still keeps keeps them
in the game probably I can take take f3
I don't know okay push em but what can
you do but I don't see a win now I don't
see it when it looks great but I don't
see how to win Queen age 7 king of one
he is just about escaping there to here
to over there
yeah I probably need to need the night
damn i know we can play Knight f6 but I
don't care much okay I'm check all right
check in you too what's not helping
Knight a5 maybe how do I get there maybe
I have to take the take the mud maybe I
have to play rook chief form huh yeah
that's probably edits that sets good
let's just fire him
hmm ok for a night f5 is also coming
night f5 ok I still have this pawn hmm I
had a porn why did you need to remember
me about this one ok what is this move
now what did you play I didn't even see
the move just trying to get the a porn
ok let's check buddy I one that I won
that game I don't know how I don't know
how poor ok sorry i couldn't those games
really take its toll I had to I didn't
you get the chit ah let's see um what
about this if you study a serious like
all God's GM preparation carefully how
much are improvement can you expect and
you play over here hmm I don't know I
already don't know the GM preparation
series it's a really this series has
great great exercises but it is on a
really high level and i don't know if i
would recommend that to most players
unless you are two thousand one hundred
or so i don't know if this is a great
idea it's it's it's tricky ok i'm just
playing the open Sicilian I mean this is
not exactly wacky but it will probably
be sharp and totally not my area so we
got the dragon um ok yeah you know it
doesn't look very aggressive at first
but I have some agressive ideas with
that
let's see if I get something interesting
out of that s the g4 base line is the
second can I go here deform OS is crazy
there is a there's an align that term a
lien plate is a debt of deadlines I
don't remember I wanted to drive kien 94
hmm but it's just a bad position for me
it doesn't look too bad right it's not
that you know that's not very attacking
like but it looks like a decent position
ok check I really want to trade Queen cm
with my aerie King position and let's
prevent night should be form yeah ok
this is not super exciting but I tried
with g4 ok let's take that and maybe
night c5 was interesting and all that I
think of it it's still interesting but I
could have played that one move earlier
yeah b7 is hanging and e4 is hanging but
before taking avoid sir is really a
risky I wonder if f5 as a move maybe
could be a move hmm now let's get the
King out of this f5 is also a question
if he wants to do that I can take
playbook g1 that's certainly nice for me
and now I'm threatening or only for
definitely
yeah let's get get this in and now see
how he's going to defend here he is not
it again it's not looking at this at all
but ok I understand b7 was hanging ok I
have to drop back no question now nitey
form is an idea in a situation where he
cannot take so he has to he doesn't he
thinks he doesn't have to do any it
doesn't have to do anything 94 what are
you playing Bishop 6 ok I play that
anyway that looks good anyway we takes
why aiya because of that resource I see
ok so what about ok this is just a ton
of checks Bishop h5 I was thinking but
it doesn't help me Bishop age 5 Bishop
t4c takes rook takes root chicks king of
eighth route g5 no text a group 35 hmm i
don't know i don't know if this Nets me
anything but it's interesting let's just
do that and a chest 960 gambia difficult
to get i think it's interesting but
they're difficult to get yeah i
calculated this and i was thinking that
this is interesting but maybe i'm
completely wrong mmm i am wrong now yes
no hand that said wasn't debated well in
a good idea he has a simple King g6 now
to to defend otherwise it would be quite
ok oh wow he's not covering that
well hey i sees through his right of
course he has some oxy to his check ok
we'll take be true I wonder who can I go
d5 voices too risky that seems really
risky
yeah I wonder if I co h for more like d5
and then checking him yeah that's
probably too risky but I want to I mean
I wanted to play sharp today then it
still isn't a good idea it remains Sam
it remains a fishy idea yeah yeah you
know my ideas to invade with the king a
king to you five and tried to but she
has a protected passer there it is it is
far too risky what I'm doing it is by
far too risky but ok let's see what is
coming up with at the end I think you
can just take the pawn down take age two
of you wants okay mmm and then he wants
to play three maybe so can check him
hmm
I really don't know what I'm doing yet
that's really a bit a bit weird e to
King d6 and what is he doing now if I go
here and push the pawn is this crisis
crazy I don't know my point is it's not
dangerous
okay i can go d 6 or not why not I don't
see why not let's go d 6
yeah rookie three kings 277 is my idea
um I don't know while rookie 3d7 rookie
too for that matter okay it starts to
check that's just one check but look the
two is probably enough to draw at least
I'm not sure if you can when maybe you
can but rookie to looks like it wrong I
have to go King c7 and he checks me
again
ok
I came threatening g7 now I don't know
if that was a great idea see I had a
does he just want to promote those pawns
that thats it's possible that she just
wants to promote his stuff down okay
let's drive t7 then what b5 now is
checking me mmm Jim I can take also
it gets really funny now I can't have to
protect this and now rookie 2 is the
threat a three rookie too okay I cannot
really win here i think i can take here
look the seven King a four and i'm poor
nerd is a check nice got the check
unfortunate yeah i didn't i didn't see
that that he can can check me
mmm I have no time I've absolutely no
time here ah now that's not that's not
good nice every plane this badly him ah
that was that was bad that was really
bad okay I shouldn't really I shouldn't
really lose this game anymore not not in
the rook endgame they're like here yeah
spent too much time but ok this is this
whole trying to try to get to win is a
Miss struck him um okay let's get going
with a new game yeah I don't know hey
there was a really weird end game let's
get a new game going
now maybe I could have gone to e8 as
possible takes a while to get a game at
the moment probably not very busy the
server at this time yeah 960 I can try I
can I'm trying for a 960 game but it's
not easy the group's opening no now i'm
not going to play the group yeah I don't
get a 960 I don't get a five minute game
it's really strange normally you get
them like like pretty quickly I can try
a three minute game yeah the bong cloud
variation I don't know what that is I
keep a right about this on reddit but I
don't know what it is I have some idea
that is probably not the most sound
opening ever but I don't know what it is
exactly all the l a-- coins hmm ok i can
play the four pawns attack against that
which is at least kind of aggressive but
it's not not something that I know at
all oh wow he's playing that one they're
dead dead super shock 93 I think ticks
ticks c4 I think I think this is how
this is this how is this is how the line
goes I think he cannot plane a 94 Queen
a4s ridiculous TX takes and what is he
doing c4 yeah I guess this one but I'm
kind of inventing stuff as we go along
ok what about can i play Bishop c4 in
this position 9c for Queen f1 check
yeah deepness is hanging ikev2 advanced
it probably what position yeah this is
why I play one Knight f3 or deform to
not get into into stuff like that where
you feel kind of lost after 11 moves hmm
how it's played Bishop g5 at some point
maybe for a temple at least it seems
that he's also not on very familiar
ground I definitely want to try to
Castle if possible maybe this is a bit
too a bit too conservative but I really
want to so I got a got castle that sets
not bad for starters and one idea is to
play Bishop sorry 95 possible he loves
that let's let's do this trying to prove
or trying to show that this Bishop down
before it's kind of a bit out of the
picture and I have possibilities on the
King side now I Bishop g5 and Knight f6
this is something that looks nice yeah
this there was a coup request for the
group yeah group was an interesting
person it seems he am he was some i read
a i read something recently and in un
chest and I maybe I already told that
that story it was it was really
entertaining it was a quote about him
and he was asked by by and by someone I
think it was a reporter or writer or
something and they asked him so are you
married and his
his reply was almost always which is
really a cool reply to that question and
that can be explained with the fact that
group was married nine times can you
imagine nine times this is a kind of
crazy it's probably more than like
Elizabeth Taylor or some of those
Hollywood Hollywood persons and what is
this night chief here Louis Knight to g5
I don't believe that one bit nah come on
thats Knight f6 check is a huge threat
yeah come on come on how is he defending
this I don't see it Knight f6 I had the
other night to g5 but then he has g6 at
least rooks rook c8 was a very relaxed
smooth like nothing's happening yeah
okay g6 Queen h4 h5 I don't believe in
that I don't Bishop takes age five at
least Larry King was he was he married
nine times nine times no I'm not married
Queen age form yeah I just play it
simple I hope that hope simple as enough
h5 Bishop takes a trifle I don't believe
there has a defense to that
yeah play first think later but it
should win that really would be strange
if it wasn't 95 push-up g6 and I'm
checkmating on age 7 it should it should
be a maid push up to six yeah eight
times it's also quite a bit yeah
opponents resigned so the four pawns
attack struck yeah but it's said let's
not one of the openings i would
recommend to play if you really don't
know what's going on so let's let's play
them the more again but it was requested
ok I've got a decline tomorrow but we
transpose into the c3 Sicilian and yeah
well this this line is not really great
for black but i'm not an expert Bishop
g4 no it's not doing that ok push-up g4
is more interesting ok but if I go here
and go Bishop f4 what are you doing
against that yeah you know I'm a very
very simple minded person sometimes how
do you protect that if you check me I go
here and then what King move on what
exactly ok yeah we got a honey position
early be five ok so I tape with a pawn I
cannot be too bad with 96 coming ok so I
have 83 if I like one a three yeah
there's no reason not to really pushing
this back well I'm getting great
positions with those wacky openings
um Wow Bishop c5 now I don't believe in
that one bit why not 94 this is guy
doing here I am I playing nonsense here
Queen 85 I just play Bishop 32 and he
resides and they get to d6 wow so okay
which one actually that's not easy hmm
oh is it I can take take b7 that's
probably probably just good whatever i
play if i take be seven or this is
blacks big point i guess there is none
right bishop f2 maybe I should have
think I thought about that Bishop f2 was
maybe a move here I can go Bishop g3 if
everything else fails even g3 is a move
I don't see the point of that one if I
go g34 Bishop g2 might be might be on
that's strange
um yeah I am a great Richard Burton we
home I'm not sure it was good in many
movies i guess yeah queen d6s dino
training queens but I've got two pawns
and end a good position so I do mind to
to trade Quincy and I'm not giving up on
anything and what about this he's giving
away the night there why cannot i cannot
take the night I don't see it looks e8
but then I go back to the six I can go
nite g6 now just back checking the rook
I don't I don't know i'm attacking the
rook there was check it's a kind of a
disastrous game him okay he had takes a
five but y al I mean the bishop moves he
has got if I the check but I really
don't think it's that problematic um
where do i go to e4 probably maybe to e
foyer I don't really see any
compensation there
Knight f6 I have Queen f5 Bishop here
maybe 22 I cannot say to this year by
the way night f5 is quite nice that
actually should force resignation I
don't see a move I mean I've got a ton
of material up ok um ok
yeah checking when you are material up
is always fun like here let's see I can
just double on the F file if I want or
or e6 um checking is not working I can
play this one though yeah and I'm
spoiled for choice in this position I
really want to make the guy but I don't
see a maid e 6 edit all wins but I don't
see I don't see a maid unfortunately
this one maybe if he takes rook c7 that
that will be made with Queen g6 coming
ok prevented that one um look here
and night f5 to trade stuff yeah
probably could have won cougar but it
did so it's sort of still pretty good
it's still pretty good
Queen d7 that's what I want to get in
yeah now we resigned yeah it was a very
nice position okay it's a it's close to
our hour one hour mark but I'm going to
try for one more game it's fun playing
this stuff just something something else
on the board knight c6 yeah I could have
deflected that yeah probably yeah I
don't know what is wrong with her own
Ian's play at the moment rachmaninoff
who is that available for lessons that's
good but doesn't tell the name um okay
what can I do here mmm it's difficult to
get a gambit styler opening here maybe
just the king's indian the classical
king's indian is normally enough
excitement do we get that no is plain g3
yet slain that's really lame yeah for
excitement I mean it's lame okay yeah
I'm not very knowledgeable here it's
been well have a lifetime since I
studied this lines there's some stuff
with taking on deform 95 I don't know if
I get this in
there is a there are this one particular
line where with bishop is six where
people keep blundering stuff let's see
Bishop somewhere with Bishop e6 but how
was that possible but should be three
probably somehow okay that's entirely
entirely different stuff okay night be
three if i go to before i will play a 3d
sixes hanging yeah yeah now i'm sitting
there in a in a g3 king's indian i have
no idea about this opening not really
when i was playing the king's indian
back in the day I was mostly allowing
the the Greenfeld or playing the
Greenfeld instead of a regular Kings
Indian against you three ok this one ok
maybe I can do this I mean I know the
bishop but I actually don't mind to
trade some stuff iam I back to see eight
okay not sure about age five but yeah I
will probably push back to f2 and then
try to play me five or c5 at some moment
okay maybe I can play 936 yeah I like
YTM that sets the position that I would
like to have at the white but yeah hello
to the chess player okay Jim let's do
that try to trade some stuff 92 might be
a move trying to keep everything on the
board but he can take it's not a problem
or anything Luke cd1 is also ok ok he
did to trade yeah White has more space
that's the simple fact in this position
97 s f5 that it's very that's a very
uncomfortable position there are really
people playing this kind of lines and
always thought they were pretty
masochistic about it white is just
better yeah I kind of stumbled into that
a bit let's see is there some way here
to try to defend this
yeah I'm in full full fledged swing-wing
mode here with g5 coming up or this one
496 yeah I know ESP should be six but
this is nothing that I can really
worried about I want to play on the dark
squares let's see if I can get something
going on the dark squares yeah I can
take the rook I know but I want to want
to get to default possible and maybe on
to F for this kind of thing g fire let's
do this if he pushes a half night f4
which is hmm at least looking a bit
tricky now if it allows Bishop b5 I mean
of course I'm losing but I'm trying to
to post problems here and I'm not able
to do that with with with slowish moves
okay let's have to support this maybe I
get in King g7 Luke AJ that that's
that's kind of interesting okay night
them yes now he's playing that well of
course things I have to be playing in a
way that I have to configure the pawn
them
oh I didn't expect that one but it's
been probably not a bad idea yeah I have
no attack we have to be totally
realistic about that I'm not attacking
him okay but still if I go Bishop a six
where's he going to f3 I guess Queen e7
h4 takes on g4 what a very good day
I'm still a bit active I mean it's not
it's not a super easy win I mean for
computer but not for a human it's pieces
I bit awkward maybe just g5 or something
I don't know I am ok he wants to take on
f4 trying to do it like that um ok
look at four I'm not recapturing and
playing hooky for rookie for any way for
26 31 Queen the sex route in 10 ok let's
bit awkward
that is a bit awkward for him rooked you
one how does he do how does he protect
against that maybe just queen III but
this is a bit scary and I have worked
III against that and he's down to 20
seconds okay um rock t 2444 supercross
pin wow that debt nice not coming back
from that move come on Queen d2 Queen d2
b sugar for him winning winning hope is
at the end yes I got that one and that
that was a that was a total swindle from
a completely lost position what's this
now you're always stepping the time or
isn't me no I'm I'm still connected yeah
he may be disconnected that's possible
it was probably quite quite quite quite
disappointing game that's it that's it
yet he has disconnected he has
disconnected I cannot do my chair to
wait until this the stick then crazier
openings you know this is the craziest I
can do really yeah I have to wait alibi
dia now now I'd have to know it it
struck wide resins maybe you really did
resign I don't know it was no strange
but ok I understand that he was
frustrating frustrated because i was
completely completely busted ok if guys
i hope you enjoyed the session it was
some some fun games but i couldn't
really do much of questions answered
yeah it was i was too focused on the on
the games i hope you enjoyed this and
i'll be on next week as well
cm